Dallas buyers club you tell us one of
your favorite stories from being on set
one of my favorites was as I didn't
recognize Matthew when I walked into the
room I was finishing a film in Dallas
and had come back to LA I was on my way
home to Birmingham to see my family for
the first time in about two-and-a-half
months and I got a call from my agents
when I landed in Houston say they wanted
to reroute me to New Orleans that I'd
been offered this role in the Dallas
buyers club but I needed to be there the
next day and I said Mitchell he said he
said in the first place and he never
does this he said say yes I said do me a
favor I'll read the script on the next
leg from Houston to Birmingham and I'll
call you when I land but I got to get
home I got to see my kids and he said
okay but they're gonna turn you right
around you're gonna go back to New
Orleans and he the last thing he said
was say yes so because he knew that he
knew the project and when I got there
because I was drawn in a little bit late
a lot was there were a lot of moving
parts and there's this wonderful crazy
french-canadian director jean-marc
vallée I adored working with him I'll be
forever grateful for the for the notes
that he gave me because he he gave my
character dimension that I might have
missed I was stepping in quickly to
something and but when I walked into the
into the hospital room the first time to
work with Matthew I was like wouldn't
you coming in you know and he's of
course he's more than ready he's
standing over there but he had lost so
much weight that he was unrecognizable
to me so so when we started the same I'm
still waiting for McConaughey to come in
and he's there and it you know it's one
of those things that kind of throw you
in the moment when you finally realized
oh we're going and you better catch up
so it actually helped me because we were
we were in the in the throes of it
before I had an opportunity to get
nervous about it
one he was wonderful in the role I mean
I you know I I was on the on an airplane
once without Pacino I did a film called
sea of love with him and we were flying
to Toronto to rehearse and he was
talking about John Gielgud in a film and
he said he's gotten free and it I didn't
know what that meant but I knew Pacino
knew what it meant and moreover the way
he said it there was a sense of
reverence about the notion that an actor
had gotten free that John Gilbert's been
doing this for a long time and so at Al
Pacino so the the the thing was he was
saying about his performance he's gotten
free well I saw that on McConaughey he
was free any impulse any thought any
movement any moment it was it was like
he was free to do whatever came to him
and that instant whatever he was playing
off of whatever preparation he had he
was utterly free with it and I thought
we did something special here we're in
something really special here the other
the other thing that I liked about it
was that I really never met Jared Leto
Leto until the premiere because they
never came out of character so I met her
but I didn't get to really talk with him
until you know much later and I love
that you know the this this sense of
it's the only film that I've ever worked
on they didn't have a grip package there
was no light no lighting it was all done
existing light only and there were
scenes where this wonderful director was
running around just torch lighting the
way with profanity in French with his
camera on his shoulder going we gotta
get this we got agree on however you say
that in French la la la la and his crew
was pretty remarkable they were they
were accustomed to his you know his
speed of pace and just to watch that to
see things happen we never went back to
our trailer ever you put your clothes on
in the morning and you better be ready
because we were on the fly and
you know some of us first thought best
thought and I enjoy that aspect of it
but I had great respect for what Matthew
and Jared we're doing in Jennifer I mean
they and Steven saw what a character he
is oh my god I got to hang out with him
and he's just a incredibly funny man you
know and I was in New Orleans that's
nice
New Orleans is nice good food probably
heavy stuff ever been on the film in
that film because all that food was so
good there's a good it was a it was a
great experience so going back to being
free is that getting out of your own way
that goes back to and where does that
come from public commitment probably
just a commitment and a belief and a
trust that you've got it go you know you
know there's a wonderful little saying
in our business if you're falling dive
and I was watching guys dive you know
and it it creates you know it kind of
creates an atmosphere you you go yeah me
too I want to play too
and I really thought in the first part
of the film that I had that you know I
think I got caught up in and I I thought
I got a little you know one-dimensional
light played in the film you know I did
what I could do on the day
you know the saying that and I'm
paraphrasing prepare freezing here stuff
rolls downhill do you think that when
you sense that a director is allowing
people to be free it sounds like this
man is very free that it rolls downhill
and then others adopt that yeah yeah I
do and you know one of the first scenes
I had he came in I you know I was
jamming I was learning trying to learn
really really quickly I haven't had to
learn that much that quickly since the
West Wing because things were fluid and
really well done but fluid and he he
came in I had learned the pages that
were you know that I'd been given well
he came in just before we were gonna go
roll em speed action with new pages and
so he and I talked it out in the next
hospital room you know I thought that
that that and he trusted me too good
you're good
go ahead now we had not you know we
didn't really have a shorthand
we were just and I was able to say but
wait what this one little thing right
here let's tell the audience something
they don't know so let's you know and he
was he was amenable to me contributing
as well
and and and yet he always said make sure
you keep him human make sure you
maintain his sense of humour make sure
you keep him human and that was that was
a great note for me because it would
have been very easy to just have been
disturb you know bureaucratic I'm the
Food and Drug Administration you you
can't come in you know and it it it
enliven the character for me but but it
did roll downhill it's starting with him
and it rolled downhill and it
fortunately for me it ran into me
you